the report is amazing it clearly
incoherently looks at each of the issues
uh in turn facing the industry and comes
to a reasonable
conclusion and that conclusion uh
supports everything our campaign has
been saying you know
british musicians are suffering
needlessly and the future of british
music is in jeopardy because of the way
that
the economics of streaming are working
presently well we'll get into that
in a little bit but you're the you're
the singer and the guitarist of
a mercury prize winning uh band
one might be forgiven for thinking that
you're raking it in uh in terms of
streaming just tell us how much you
reckon you make in about a year
in terms of streaming uh revenue um
approximately a few hundred pounds maybe
and very very little you know i'd
i'd rather not be here i'd rather be
writing songs
rather than having a scrap with um
a bunch of multinational corporations
about how much money they
keep in their pockets and i mean that's
that's really the funny thing streaming
is this brilliant
brilliant thing it's wonderful it gives
us all the ability to have all of music
in our back pocket
i love it as a music lover i think it's
the most incredible service to have ever
and but unfortunately your your viewers
um who i'm sure are fellow music lovers
their subscriptions are going into the
back pockets
of a very few number of multinational
corporations and
and that's the situation um of of the
ten pounds that you maybe pay for
for me every month yeah absolutely i
mean
a pound might get some musicians that's
interesting so less than a pound in
let's say a 10 pound subscription factor
could easily be that i mean it's really
incredibly low i was talking to my
friend
i remember talking to ian brodie a
couple of years ago we've all been
singing um
three lions an awful lot recently and i
was talking to him a couple of years ago
and when that song was number one during
the 2018 world cup i think he said that
it was about
it made him about six or seven thousand
pounds now
people like me and ian don't need to
make more money we've we've done very
well with our careers but the problem
here is
if we're going to say to young people
who want to who love music and want to
make music and want to have a career
that if what they're aiming for the
absolute top
of their career the apex of getting a
number one
means the equivalent of six thousand
pounds in their pocket
i'm sure you can see that there's a bit
of a problem
yeah enormously in terms of trying to
get more people into the industry
absolutely
what what about the consumer because of
course we've all got used to paying as
you said around 10 pounds for our
spotify account
or any other streaming service is there
a way
of consumers still getting those low
prices or are they going to have to get
used to paying more in order to reward
artists fairly in the first instance
i don't think um that consumers are
gonna have to pay for it
you know too much of the money look
you've got
universal music the biggest record
company in the world
made a billion dollars of profit last
year
and whereas the average musician earns
something about
around 20 000 pounds a year and
and that income is is usually at least
in part
teaching or other or other um associated
uh
things so you know that shows you the
the the problem that we have
warner music six of their top executives
last year
paid themselves a stock bonus of 593
million dollars six people
to to what's i just want to ask you on
that is this then a problem more
of those big uh music companies those
big record labels
uh or is it a problem of streaming
services or is it the contractual
arrangements that they have between the
two where where does the problem lie
it's actually all three and that's the
written that's why that's why this
report calls for a complete reset
the the contracts which artists have
with
labels haven't really come on
significantly since the 20th century
when labels had
very high costs for distribution and
manufacturing and
and scouting around the country now
those costs are gone and yet
the the money that they're the margin
that has grown is not being passed onto
the artist it's just going into profit
the streaming services have kept the
prices
down for 12 years which is you know with
inflation has driven down the price of
music by 25
alone and then when you talk about the
deals between the streaming services and
the labels well artists aren't even
allowed to see them
they're protected by what are known as
ndas so
so artists can't even find out really
what they're earning
um nda's being non-disclosure agreements
of course listen i want to ask you one
last question before we have to let you
go but
how how much has the pandemic brought
this crisis into focus given that all
live music events were stopped for
for a certain amount of time enormously
you know i started the broken record
campaign
in april of last year specifically
because i realized
that musicians were about to lose
almost all of their income and streaming
was left alone recorded music streaming
was left
and it provides little or no income to
almost any
uh musician it's certainly the sort of
i hate to use the word middle class but
a sort of middle tier of musician who a
professional who
whose names you probably know and love
they're not getting paid and people who
are already successful
are not getting paid i mean my my
campaign is supported by the likes of
paul mccartney
kate bush the rolling stones
and the list goes on and on and on so
you know
this isn't musicians who are haven't had
a little success
saying there's a problem here this is
everybody